[Music]
okay so this
is my spoiler review of cobra kai
season three i'll be breaking down every
single episode
if you have not watched the whole season
do not watch this review yet
wait till you've watched all the season
then come back to this review
so i'm someone i grew up as a kid loving
the karate kid i watched all the films
when i was really young
and then i hadn't seen them in forever
and they kind of faded out in my memory
i heard about cobra kai i wanted to know
what was all about so recently i
rewatched all the karate kid movies
then i watched the cobra kai and i loved
season one
and i was so so about season two so i
had my expectations right in the middle
here for season three so
starting with episode one aftermath what
really works well to start a season off
is that everybody is in a bad spot and
it actually shows you how effective
having miguel
fall and hurt himself set the stage for
season three
because it was something that was
desperately needed to shake everything
up and have people react to something
and kind of tilt their characters and
that happens here where
now robbie's on the run johnny lawrence
is a drunken mess
and then daniel larusso his name is
tarnished
his business is affected so everyone's
fighting something here
conflict is beginning right from the
start now we also get shifts
in the cast here where the character of
yasmin
front wedgie who was not in season two
is back and
we actually lose aisha here who was a
big player in both season one and two
and they say she moved to a private
school she wasn't written in this season
and i was surprised because again
she's always been there from the start
and i thought it was interesting choice
that she wasn't in this season she could
always come back obviously but i also
felt a little bad for the actress
because i know
she had posts about on social media so i
do hope we'll see her again in the
future but you'll see also characters
like
moon kind of fade out a bit here i think
she's only in episode one
but why that's positive note what works
on cutting some of the character time of
the younger actors in this show is that
they fixed the big problem i had in
season two where it really leaned into
this teen drama
where season three you could clearly
tell they got
back to the adults and they purposely
did this because they know
that's what worked so well in season one
and season three is mostly scenes with
adults
the main plot lines are about the adults
not the kids
where that kind of shifted in season two
to the kids which i think hurt it and
where it works so well with our main two
adults in daniel and johnny is that they
blame themselves for what happened
with all this fighting and what happened
to miguel and robbie and
it sets the stage well in episode one
that daniel sees crease
and creases laying all the disses to him
he even uses his own line can't blame
robbie no bad students against daniel
which
was great and i like chris talking crap
about my aggie
to set off daniel here really works well
the show's so
good at bringing back things from karate
kid movies and tying them in
and they do that with tone they always
give it that fun 80s tone
but also character beats and way they
present things just like the movies with
having
literally going to old footage from the
movies or from past episodes like the
movies would do
and a lot of motivational speak through
thoughts even
i like how they had miguel here when he
was in his coma he was thinking about
what johnny had told him
and motivating him even in his like
sleep well they lost more things with
the script here just even having
johnny and daniel how they would be
brought together to be in this like
buddy cop film is to find robbie
something to temporarily put their
beef aside for the greater good and
thank god when we see robbie here he got
a haircut
that was great in season two he had like
this bob
little things like that are huge
it just can change a character
completely and you can take the
character more seriously and already
here they're setting up
this merger between miyagi doe and which
will eventually be
johnny's dojo eagle fang and daniel has
this line
we can't let them suffer because of our
issues only way to end this is by
working together and i love the end
episode where
miguel wakes up with the close-up on his
face from the coma and it's like
jon snow when he's revived in game of
thrones
and it was nice to add a little tribute
to the actor rob garrison who played
tommy from the films who was in season
two
but he passed away after season two so
it was nice to put a little tag at the
end of the episode for him
and for me this episode i'm gonna give
it an 8.7 but the positive for it was
it was better than any episode in season
two for me and that was already
hope and i could already tell they had a
good plan here just again having such
good pieces to set up here that was
already evident in the first episode so
it's a little surprising here is episode
2
nature vs nurture we actually get a
flashback here
in san fernando valley in 1965 and we
see
the beginnings now of this backstory of
crease there's big moments to learn
about chris's character because we
learned his mother killed himself which
is
such a traumatic thing we see when he
first saw a pamphlet to go into the army
and it lays the beginning now of a
couple crease flashbacks we get which i
think
really worked well which i'll get more
into as we see more of it but what i
really love about how they set up now
with these three dojos but the three
teachers
in johnny crease and daniel to me it's
like this
scale of white gray and black and that
would be white being daniel
gray being johnny and black being
creased you're seeing these
three different types of school of
karate and when i'm talking about crease
being
this dark way of how he does things i
mean he
kicks someone out of his dojo for not
feeding
the mouse to the snake i thought that
was great i like how they also had chris
and hawk
have this relationship together and he's
just bringing the worst out in hawk
i love what they do with hawk this
season especially because he's got to
his worst point here as a person
and they kind of fixed where miguel
had an extreme switch a lot of people
complained about the end of season one
where he kind of just became this like
evil guy
but it was such a flip from someone who
was so likable at the beginning of
season one
where they kind of brought him a little
bit back down to his center in earth
and it made miguel likeable again which
was important
and they kind of let hawk take that role
which was made more sense because of how
bullied he was and how he was already on
that path of going extreme for revenge
so hawk fills a better role of being
this extreme
type now under crease and what concerned
me about season two was it would lean so
much in teen drama it forgot about
the comedy here and what season one did
so well was it had such a good comedy in
it and constantly throwing jokes in but
it didn't take away from the heart
and drama at the core of the show where
season two kind of just left the comedy
aside
and it was missing and they kind of
brought it back a decent amount here in
season three i wouldn't say it's as good
as season one's comedy but it's
clearly better than season two and they
tried more and the best is when they
lean into johnny being like a big kid
and danielle being this parent type and
they clash at that and there's nothing
better than seeing johnny trying to use
facebook or even here in this episode
when he's eating the corn nuts and
flipping them up and
daniel's like please don't get them in
my car and they do a good job at lining
up the flashbacks of crease to what he's
doing in present day like his
best memory c of him is saving this girl
at the diner who would end up being his
girlfriend
it's lined up with how he does a good
thing for tori and takes care of her
creepy landlord and pays for her rent
and this is how you recruit tory but it
only shows little blips
of the good increase there's very few
good increase but they do a good job in
the flashbacks because as we get to
you'll understand more
how he became this monster and where
that decision to be a monster
happened so they smartly don't make him
too sympathetic either but they do
effectively give him a little humanity
here which i like and i love about cobra
kai is you never know what to expect
just like the karate kid movies anything
can happen and i think
it's good it leads into that cheesiness
because that is the tone of karate kid
and
i love just a scene here where you're
getting a van car chase here with johnny
and daniel and they start to fight these
thugs together that was a crowd pleaser
seeing them
work together for a bit but what's great
is every time they try to work together
they always start fighting
they can't agree on something so they
always keep you on edge with these two
together they don't just make them make
up and be best friends which i like they
always are
going at it what i really like where the
writing was strong was
this narration of chris here talking to
his students
ending with this monologue saying your
whole life you're told to be good
all perspective no good or bad only weak
or strong you shed our weaknesses to
show our strength so it's a really good
job again just
showing you the mindset of a character
like chris and what his core
belief is and that is how he acts in
life and that's how he trains people and
being like he says unstoppable so
you got kind of goosebumps there so i'm
gonna give this episode an 8.9 i thought
this one was just ended really strong
and i like they start introducing these
flashbacks for chris
so he won't just be a one-note villain
like i said look at the time of dialogue
how much more is with the adults that we
really care about i'm not
totally dissing the kid actors here or
the kid characters but
come on what we really want to see also
is the people we grew up with and
have been laid as the focus of the show
and you gotta at least give them a
little more of an edge here and they're
doing that so
episode three now you're going to pay
starts off a little slow because they
have to get through
this drama with danny larusso and his
dealership and losing people
and it really is just to set up a reason
for him to go
to japan and eventually okinawa so it
starts a little slow off the gates
episode but
again i love this humor they got going
with johnny he is a great humorous line
where he says
to his friend bobby i still don't get
how they get the coffee and the cake
when he's eating a coffee
i thought that was again some of the
best comedy writing the show does is
with johnny and
to add to the johnny humor here there's
another scene where when johnny's trying
to get a job
so he can pay for miguel's surgery and
they're asking about his resume
and they find out he's a criminal record
the best is assaulted miners he says
the way he says it and not taking it so
seriously was just great
and how awful that sounds so they do a
good balance here with the script
because
they have sam take over and take lead of
miyagi doe
gives her a little more interest in her
story and
switches things up with daniel with him
going to japan and it ends on a good
cliffhanger this episode because now we
get the tease about
our karate kid 2 characters coming in
but i'm giving this episode 8.1
it was one of my least favorites there's
a lot of mouse to feed you had to drag
through a little bit of this
car dealership story to get to where we
need to go it wasn't that enjoyable it's
a little flat now episode four
the right path daniel decides to go to
okinawa here when he's in japan
and i love how well they did everything
attached to karate kid 2.
karateka 2 was my least favorite karate
kid movie
yes sue me i like the next karate kid
better than karate kid too
but i really love how they did karate
kid two
characters in this season i liked it
better than anything in karate kid 2.
i like this theme going on about how
daniel could still visit people in
spirit
even though miyagi is gone it's funny to
see the village from karate kid 2 is now
just all retail that mr
sato brought out seeing a red lobster
and gaff but there was something magical
about when he first saw
kamiko dancing when they lock eyes now i
will say in this episode the bullying
scenes on the other end of it with hawk
we're getting a little repetitive
because we see it happen
with dimitri science project we see it
happen at the soccer match
i was worried season three was going to
start doing this again where sometimes
some of the beats with the bullying
especially
keep repeating themselves or get tired
but they didn't thank god but this
episode in particular they did which i
wasn't crazy about
i think we got the point already by now
that hawk is on a different level
right now and that he's crazy i don't
think we need to keep reasserting that
so back in the story in okinawa i love
camiko still calls him daniel's son and
he sees there's no ring on her finger
and she's like no guy fought to death
for me just again some of these lines
tie so well to these old
films and really do it justice and i
like that this story is a nice escape
for this storyline of daniel being in
this midlife crisis and he can kind of
re-center himself here and i love they
are
at aunt yuki's old place and how it
really worked having miyagi
wrote love letters to yuki and we can
read from those
and it's going to bring the tears out
here for serious karate kid fans having
the lines like miyagi talking about
on his death bed in his letter i got
lost until i met
daniel's son and that he was a guiding
light to him that's some great
just payoff from stories continuing on
from the karate kid films to this
show and they do justice with the
writing with how miyagi would talk like
i love this line in life we always lose
our
way but it's the people not the signs
that guide us back to the right path
i heard that in a car commercial exactly
how miyagi would talk it's a great
inspirational quote
and it has that little punchline at the
end which is great i gotta say though
acting wise
i'm blown away how good kumiko is here
she absolutely brings 100
but unfortunately ralph macchio
struggles because it's
a really high range scene to bring
emotion here and i don't think he
totally is up to par with her in this
scene but again it's still a great scene
and really can get you emotional here
and it's great wake up
for daniel and it transitions well to
johnny waking up now
with miguel he's getting miguel out of
his slumpy ways as he's getting out of
his slump
and i love we got a quiet this season
it's my favorite thing running in the
show
so i'm happy we got at least one and it
was here in this episode like it's
titled everyone getting on the right
path here
and again lining up similar story as
well where chris
now appears to robbie but the other end
which tricks you first because you think
it's bad chosen appears
to daniel i really wish they didn't put
this in the trailer though chosen that
would have shocked me so much
if i didn't know he was coming i would
have been like are they gonna do that
but it's so cool when you see
them bring these actors back so at this
point in the season when you watch these
first four episodes i would say that the
okinawa story is a standout
and that johnny's is pretty solid and
that stuff going on with the kids at
school is very meh but this episode i
would give in 8.6 so episode five
is called miyagi dough it's one of the
longer episodes of 38 minutes
i love they open this episode the
flashback from the films like the films
would do themselves
and here we get to see the chosen and
daniel fight to the death from karate
kid 2. and the shocker here is that in
current time chosen actually bows to
daniel and
it's a great come around because it's so
important they showed that flashback
of the movie because you see daniel
spared him and
remember chosen was a complete
psychopath and it's cool we see now
the original miyagi doe and there's
miyagi artifacts here
but there's more to that lore of the
miyagi way which children will
kind of reveal a bit with daniel but i
do want to point out in this episode we
see
back in america that the character of
anthony daniel's son
was always kind of used as comic relief
always playing games always eating but
he looks completely different here
he has like one line the whole season
that was a little disappointing to me
but i do think they're saving him and i
think they'll obviously go more into his
character because he
is karate kid's child here but you see
it's interesting because chosen's kind
of showing
some of the ways he learned from his
master who was also under
miyagi's father and there is this belief
in the miyagi line
sometimes you have no choice but to kill
and again like daniel says this is stuff
yagi
most likely didn't show him to protect
daniel and i thought it worked great
because you thought for a second when
him and chosen her fighting
chosen was actually going to kill him
here but he just laughed so we see how
different his character is now
we could assume taught daniel like
daniel says
about tsumiaki pressure points and
that's going to have payoff at the end
in the finale which we'll get to but i
love on the other end of this episode
where
johnny now starts his version of rehab
for miguel he's lighting a shoelace on
fire which is just hysterical
but some of the best humor with johnny
here is he's writing in a notebook at
one point you see
a list he titles how to fix miguel's
legs an exclamation point and he writes
electric shock hypnosis then tony
robbins and then
lsd this needs to be a t-shirt you can
buy
i thought this was one of the funniest
visual gags of the season and i love
when he cracks open the laptop to see
webmd
he says webermed but i do like they show
this moment in sync where
robbie and sam are both fading away from
the miyagidou teachings where robbie's
beating up a bunch of people in prison
and sam is thinking of revenge against
kopa kai but this is where it gets
really amped up in that crease way of
his version of cobra kai with
tori now and hawk and tory's looking for
sam
in this laser tag and hawk literally
breaks dimitri's arm
the actor of hawk is amazing hawk is one
of my favorite characters they've
developed through this show i think he's
the best developed character of any of
the kids
from the top to now what the actor does
so well as he
shows in his face the hesitation and
that there's still some of that kid
who's best friends with dimitri in there
which will also get pay off later in the
finale which we'll get to but they
couldn't have tied the story of chosen
and daniel and all these karate kid2
storylines better than having the scene
with chosen
and daniel and chosen apologizing and
daniel forgiving that was really
effective
and to see that changed man and it was
even cool this
love you see they have for these movies
these writers of this show
like to think of that this dealership
story would be tied around because
the person who's got her hand in it was
yoona who
daniel saved in the typhoon from karate
kid 2. i mean this is the little girl
here and they bring her back it's like
they go all out with this universe
that's what makes it so exciting you
never know who you're gonna see from the
old films and
they justify when they bring them back
it's not a cheesy way it's an effective
way and it
serves the theme here about the quote
aunt yuki said put good out into the
world and good will come back to you and
it's just an
awesome payoff from what daniel did to
save that girl's life and now it's
coming back years later i teared at this
even
and it gets that effective feel goodness
to the show when
now johnny's really winning miguel back
and now winning the mom back carmen but
what's awesome is now this ends on the
cliffhangers episode it goes back to
the end of season two's cliffhanger i
was worried they were gonna have that
cliffhanger with ali's friend request
and never come to it this season because
she wasn't in the trailers but thank god
they did because you get excited i'm a
huge fan of the actress elizabeth shue
especially in her recent work in the
boys so you're like okay here we go
you had a little goosebumps so this
episode was an 8.9 for me at this point
this season it was the best one
since the premiere of season three so
now let's shift episode six
king cobra so we're back now to with
john cree's flashback in 1968 in vietnam
what i like about these flashbacks
they're to the point they don't make it
a whole episode i think that would kill
the tone of this karate kid universe but
they
lightly drop it in and i like the detail
like his
crazy sergeant in vietnam is the one he
learned
these ways and he even smokes a cigar
like crease will eventually and i love
this
thing they keep doing where when his
teacher was teaching him these
militarian ways of karate
it's laid over him in current time
teaching the kids in cobra kai
that way about being all in but where we
see now
in current time hawks again great
character development is when
kyler his former bully joins cobra kai
and you see that mask start to come off
of hawk it was really crazy and awesome
to see the other bully though that comes
with kyler
just talk kick the crap out of him goes
full insane here it just hit hard
no pun intended and my only complaint
though
with having kyler come back with hawk
was they kind of just become
buds later on and they don't address it
enough kyler and hawk i feel like they
still need to have a big moment here
that never came
and i also think that was a missed
opportunity in the finale where when we
see hawk come full circle and back
around i thought that would have been a
great moment for him to fight kyler and
that did not happen but i'll get more
into that when we get to the finale so
we see though back in the crease
flashbacks
his captain's blaming him because kris
did a just thing
not wanting to kill a fellow troop
member but his captain blames him now
for the death of other people
this will weigh on crease as a person
and start to mess him up in the brain a
bit so like i said just the right amount
of sprinkle here
of chris's story but not to take away
from the whole
main plot and in that main plot
especially when we focus in on johnny
i like that as johnny helps me go miguel
helps johnny
calling johnny out for helping people
and then leaving and saying you are a
sensei
truly embrace it and he starts walking
again when he's yelling at johnny which
was great and that
theme about him embracing who he is that
sensei comes full circle with the
facebook photos because he
takes down those photos that weren't
really him and puts up the ones with him
in the dojo that's who i am i am a
sensei and i love that daniel and amanda
try to pull this move
to get chris kicked out with the rent of
the dojo but
kris takes care of the landlord's guys
and the landlord
not to be messed with and he sends the
snakes over to the dealership and says
to prepare your students for battle i
thought that was just classic awesome
crease so this one
really good episode another 8.9 which a
lot of these episodes will fall at
just solid stuff and the pace here
really starts to be really good here
feeling like season one again where
there's just a nice flow to it so
episode seven
obstacles is definitely clearly now
trying to
address the issues with sam's character
especially season two where she hasn't
really grown
there's not much interesting going on
with her psyche we need to
make her a little more of a deeper
character right so they do that
effectively because they show her this
nightmare of tory kicking the crap out
of her and she's got this like ptsd from
what tori did to her rightfully so
so it's a nice story arc with her that
will come full circle and again get a
nice payoff where she will face her fear
of tori
and grow as a character there and i like
they line up daniel wine to reopen
miyagi dough while johnny's starting
his new dojo i love that it's just in
the park he figures out he can do
because it's free
and i like that having miguel come back
to his senses be more of a
likable character he sees when he goes
back to school what's happened in his
absence and how bad
cobra kai's got and someone like hawk
but i love he says to johnny
cobra kai they drank all the kool-aid
and johnny just goes what's wrong with
kool-aid
absolute gold i also like now they blend
a little karate kid 3 in here when
daniel's trying to
comfort sam about this fear of someone
who's just really
scary and he brings up mike barnes which
i'm sure we'll get to see a little taste
of
next season but they do justice to
crotica 3 because my favorite thing
about karate kid 3 is the end
and that quote miyagi says must not lose
to fear stay focused
i'm also someone in this unpopular camp
where i really like karate kid 3.
i thought it was super strong
thematically and that was coming to that
line there with miyagi and i like daniel
sanders sam i'll always be there to help
you like miyagi was for me
again just great job by this writing
team to effectively
use the old movies to make sense with
the driving the plot here so we even see
yasmin's now changed as a character from
being front wedgied
and is actually warming up to dimitri
she has a nice moment where she signs
his cast
i am someone who's not a crazy fan of
dimitri as much as i was in season one
where i thought i
overused him to season two because every
single line of this character
is a quick quip or a joke and i think
it's too much
it's like okay use dimitri sparingly it
works that way but when you overdo it
it's a problem but they did a good job
with him season three because they
brought it down a bit with dimitri lines
they they kept it more balanced like
season one or season two it was just
overboard dimitri where then you feel
like
you're watching a teeny show on netflix
and i love they got johnny in the park
now with the red jacket like he wore in
karatekid1 and he decides to name it
eagle fan karate that she takes down the
cobra and i like that cobra kai shows up
here
and johnny's sticking up the crease here
and we see kind of the
playing field laid out of who's on what
team get you hype so
again 8.9 keeping the pace and just
solid stuff here so episode 8 the good
the bad and the badass
great title best title of the season
seems like it was written by johnny
lawrence himself and you see miyagi does
reopen again and like i said i love how
they got this cut between the three ways
of teaching between johnny daniel
and chris and i think it's smart when
they do this where robbie doesn't want
anything to deal with daniel or johnny
because it's the one thing that really
brings johnny and daniel together are
the concern for robbie here and not
losing him to crease and on miguel's
side i'm happy
to make him amazing at karate right away
like they realistically
showed his physical skills improved
slowly and i actually like this story
where the city cancels the all valley
tournament it's a payoff from earlier in
the season where
basically the town's against karate
because of the incident in season two
and them sticking up for karate the kids
on behalf of their parents who are weak
about it so
it's the kids here really shine pushing
their teachers to stick up for their
love of karate where it's
the town has lost faith in it and what
i'm saying about where the show
shines with feel good moments it's here
when miguel is saying how much johnny's
helped him as a sensei and how much
karate has helped him now robbie's just
pissed he's seen miguel and sam about to
kiss
he goes now to crease setting up already
here for some season four
stuff that's gonna be big and another
great episode this is an 8.9 again for
me
i've never had a show where i
consistently give the same rating per
episode
but it's just constantly the same amount
of solid here going on in this streak of
episodes and it's a really brisk good
pace and it's setting up an exciting
finale so episode nine
feel the night is the most christmasy
episode it's exciting because it starts
with
ally back elizabeth shu and you see that
johnny's got
carmen back miguel's mom's sleeping with
her but he's conflicted because now
the love from his childhood ally's back
in town but you see
they go back and have a date at golf and
stuff after their lunch
they're about to kiss but what this does
well with johnny and allen's
relationship it closes the book on it
here because it's that theme about
great to visit the past and close some
things up
and like he apologized to her but it
doesn't mean to make that your future
and try
to do it again and that he eventually
ends up with carmen
at the end of the finale as much as a
fan i'd want to see aly and johnny
together
it would fall under that maybe two
fanservicey was not a great theme behind
it so i think they made the right choice
here i do
think though that as much as i love this
shoe i think she
felt a little odd playing ally and i
think that's a tough task
because ali is kind of a thin character
from the first movie so she's jumping
into this
from a very old character that wasn't
very fleshed out from the film
and it felt a little off
and i don't know if it's on her or just
the tall task of bringing a character
like ally back with a lot of screen time
but there was something a little just
awkward about it like i still felt like
elizabeth she was just
not totally settled into the part that
she felt a little
off about it but you see now robbie is
shifting to the robber who we originally
met
from season one that was just jaded and
angry and
hawk is getting jealous of his attention
he's getting from kris
but the big development in this episode
is that sam and miguel are the ones that
think of bringing
johnny and daniel's dojos together to
take down the bigger evil increase which
i really
love that and you see chris finds out
about this and tells tori
to set up the stage for a big fight in
the finale so this episode i'm actually
gonna give an 8.7 i was a little let
down
i thought it was a little slow for a
penultimate episode in a season
and i don't think the daniel alley
and johnny story that was started here
and then finished in the finale was
all that great so opening this finale
titled december 19th
we get the final flashbacks of crease in
this episode while we're in north
vietnam and it's like
this deer hunter-esque scene where we
get
something that is to the death in front
of an audience but they're just fighting
here to the death i love that it's above
cobras nice touch and i love just if we
look at this episode's flashbacks with
john crease
you see the moment he decided to go
the way of cobra kai and his darkness
set in
was when he decides to let his commander
not have mercy and lets him fall
when their fight didn't even have to
happen anymore because they could have
escaped together but he was so angry
about him not telling him about his
girlfriend dying rightfully so
but that was the character choice that
changed him forever to
not give him mercy and he became a
different man the man we see today so
that
again really showed a great way in that
moment to justify
okay now we know where chris is now we
know why he became the way he did
and the moment he changed and decided to
do something
not for the good but for bad and it
would make sense then why he is still
doing these
awful things today i did like though
with daniel and johnny here
in front of ali they're fighting and ali
says let's just hope our kids are more
involved than we are and it cuts them
now all fighting in the lorusso house it
shocked me because i thought the finale
would be the all valley tournament
but i was worried at first so they
decided to do the house fight because i
was excited to see the valley tournament
but then i was happy to see no we're
still gonna get that they're just
setting up for next season i wasn't
crazy though about this christmas music
bleeding in
to the fight i think they kind of forced
the christmas theme into the finale i
don't think it was as important it kind
of took away from
how important these scenes were to
finish off the season to kind of
blend that holiday music on i thought
was just not effective but we get some
payoffs here in the fights i like that
tori and sam had this little
showdown and she faces her panic attacks
and her fear of tory
it's a nice touch with the miyagi photo
being hit by tori
but like miyagi would come into daniel's
head to help him
her father comes into her head we see
hawk who's already
they developed it works his flip now to
help demetri because they've already had
his hesitation moments
in the season but again i wish he went
after kyler here
and we got the payoff between their long
beef and the man who
made him into who he is really is kyler
but maybe they want to keep hawke
in the more light version he's going now
and not get revenge on his bully i could
also see that as well but i still i
think would have preferred that but you
see ali has this important line where
she's like
to johnny and daniel you guys are more
like each other you want to admit
this is a theme of the season in
particular and they both actually come
to admit they have faults in their
rivalry which i think is really
important and
is something you can justify through the
karate kid movies to now in cobra kai
and they've made their point
and they've proven their point the
writers so good job on that like i
already said
ally and johnny realize it can't happen
between them and
they go to this theme about let the past
be the past
and live for today and it triggers him
to realize he loves carmen but this will
lead to him seeing miguel
hurt and this is where i love now my
favorite moment of the season
is when johnny appears to crease and
they get a showdown here in front of his
son robbie and again cutting well
between these flashbacks of
now johnny fighting his master flashing
back to kris finding his in vietnam
and then i love larusso shows up so
we're getting all these things now that
huge fans are crying kid you gotta love
to see this and how about that when
crease was about to kill the russo
chosen kicks into
danny's head and i think he was thinking
about obviously killing
crease here thinking of the miyagi
pressure point he learned from chosen
but his kids showing up stopped that
moment
which would have been bad judgment on
the russo's part but i love how they set
up season four where
chris is like we'll settle this in the
tournament and that robbie now is
full-on crease here and that we still
know tori is as well so it's
setting up a big big stage now for the
next season and i love we got
hawk now in this team and that we see
them join up and you had to get
goosebumps at miyagi darwin johnny shows
up
we got both these teams together and
they're gonna teach together
to take down crease and it worked with
the phil collins cover
and what really got me hyped you knew
this already from the earlier
flashbacks how the actor even looked
like the character of terry silver
but they even saying karate kid 3 that
terry silver owes crease for what he did
for him in vietnam so what a pull by
these writers to think of that to lead
to an awesome setup of terry silver
coming into the show with having now
crease falling now
terry on the phone here that got me so
excited now and i love the end with
johnny saying ready let's begin
i love this finale it gets a 9.7 for me
it's such an awesome type of
setup for a next season type of finale
and i think we got enough payoff here to
justify
it being more of a setup than a climax
so for me averaging all together these
scores i'm gonna give season three and
8.8
i think it's a huge improvement over
season two which makes me so happy
it clearly looked at complaints that
were of season two i know a lot of
people like season two
but there were a lot of people like me
who were disappointed compared to season
one
and i think a lot of people have voiced
these complaints or got too much
teen drama didn't have as much humor and
they clearly
went out this season to fix those things
by you see
there's more adult dialogue here we
spend more time with johnny and daniel
than the kids
and the humor is back here still again
not as magical season one season one
just had everything clicking
in that balance of humor and drama and
feel good but this one
got back to what works and it worked
really well so
i think it's not as good as season one
but that's a tall task but
way better than the season two so i'm
really excited i'm hyped for season four
and i really am excited to see now terry
silver come to the picture because
they've made it that exciting
effectiveness like the marvel universe
or star wars where you're just pumped at
who can appear
and like i said if you want to know my
karate kid movie rankings i love the
first one the best
but i actually like the next karate kid
second then the third karate kid and
then last the second one
it's an unpopular opinion but that's
what makes me excited that
they've already said that it's all canon
even the next karate kid so
i'm excited knowing that if we know
season three was
really focused on karate kid two that
we know looking up season four is going
to be crack at three i hope season five
can pull off
bringing back hillary swank from the
next karate kid to play julie again
because that would just be an
accomplishment on the show's
own merits thinking that this started on
youtube
original series brought back and it's
blown people away how good it is
it has no right to be as good as it is
as many people say i agree with that
statement but it is
and if they can get an a-list actor like
hillary swank now to join in it would
just
represent how successful the show's been
and i think there is more to tell with
that character
of julie and i think that's even more of
a timely type of story the next karate
kid so i think it could blend
in to cobra kai really well the sky's
the limit for this show and they're
doing a good job at pacing out and not
pulling out all the cards yet they don't
want to burn out because there's only so
much you can take from the movie and
they justify it
and make it good on its own story let me
know down below what you thought of the
season give me any your thoughts on
the episodes the season as a whole what
you're excited about with season four
i'd love to hear your thoughts i read
every comment try to respond as many as
i can
if you like what i do here i ask for a
two dollar monthly donation there's a
paypal link down below
that will let me do more videos for you
guys and do this full time it's my dream
and i appreciate any support i can get
please follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram for more of me
and please please make sure to subscribe
to my channel it helps me in so many
ways you have no idea i do a bunch of tv
shows movie reviews i also do celebrity
interviews you want to check those out
and i'll see you next time